all right anne
welcome back hi so
the last time you were here you told me
about what happened to you
was that a figaro um no
well i left front breaker board but it
didn't happen i don't think we were
you're on another street um or where
were you even on the street
i was looking to another street another
place wherever i told you
yeah i left with a friend that i trusted
and you got beaten up and
all kinds of crazy stuff for like three
days yes that
well i i left with a friend from
february who ended up somewhere else
right it's a horrible story so what's
going on in your life since since then
um taking it one day at a time and um
trying to catch up with everything i
finally caught up with my
rent whereas my living situation so
now you know instead of owning them so
many hundreds i'm back to pay at 80
a day which is hard because it's like
once you pay 80 you only get a few hours
out of a day if you relax and then you
you have to um be right back out there
to do it again and again and again you
know what i'm saying and it's
it's really it takes a toll on you it
really does so are you still working
yes the same way you were i have no
choice you have no choice i have to
i mean i don't want to be homeless in
the streets
you know or nothing like that you know
i'm still trying to build everything
back
up um everything is still pretty
basically hard
you know i'm saying um
it's like um
you succeed one day
and you get like maybe
maybe an hour maybe two to feel good
because you
did this or whatever but in reality
you're
just it's never ending it's never ending
because you got me
every single day you have to deal with
this
you know a lot of times lately i've been
sleeping a lot
i've been sleeping a lot it's like
um i do what i have to do to survive but
i i just
you know i'm tired but you're living
like it sounds like day by day
day by day hour by hour minute by minute
second by second
is it's like
um being in the middle ocean and you're
trying to swim to the shore to get out
but these waves are steady pushing you
back and you're not able to get to that
shore you're right there
but you get this wave that's going to
push you back so many feet
and then you got to swim harder and
harder and harder to try to make it and
you're so
tired you know you feel like it's just
going to end
you know what i'm saying it's just
that's how it feels you know basically
that's how it is
and has it been harder to do this kind
of work since what happened to you
oh yeah
yeah you know i have to pray a lot and i
have to just hold my head up and it's
like
okay we're going to get through this day
we're going to do this and you know what
i'm saying it's like but i'm i'm
paranoid all the time now
i'm very much afraid because um
it's like every every car that i get in
is like
is this person going to try to hurt me
is this person going to try to do
something to me
you know it's really really scary now
you know what i'm saying but
i still got to do what i got to do to
survive you know
you know it's kind of
i only think i did different this time
okay i talked to a friend of mine that
she works also so
she told me about a school and it's uei
uh you know because i had went to school
so i wanted to go to school and maybe
that will
help change and everything like that i
did the whole application
everything talked to people online and
then we got to the financial aid part
they said that um i had student loans
and stuff so
all of a sudden everything just stopped
right there and then
oh well if you get this
once you get this part uh took care of
everything like that
they called me back they just cut my
whole
application over and that right there
just
took a toll on me because it's like wow
for real you know
you know so i've been kind of
i would say um doubtful now
because i tried to take another turn do
something positive and i got shut down
on that
so it's like i feel like um
you know not gonna i just had a birthday
and
and everything is just
it's just life i [ __ ] up life
yeah hope is hope is an important thing
to have well yeah then you get that
yeah i try to tell myself okay you can
do something about this situation with
the financial aid maybe you could still
go to school
you know what i'm saying and um it's
like it seemed like
everything in this world walked around
money money money
money materials and things and that just
really [ __ ] me up it bothers me
you know it really does because it's
like no matter what you do
you know more money you see the more
problems you have
you know i'm saying you can't give
forward that's why so many girls we
can't get out of this situation because
we got everyday things going on
you know if you're trying to live a life
and you have no other choice
you know what can you do there are less
expensive places to live than california
no no i
the less the lesser i don't see that
you're from texas right yeah moving back
to texas must be cheaper
i can't and i'm embarrassed to say but i
got kicked out of the state of texas
when i was younger so i can't go back to
texas i can't go back
no so um
it's like where i stay right now i'm
really comfortable
you know because when i'm inside my
place i'm in my own world
and i don't really realize where i'm at
unless i open my door and go outside
but it's like you know it's like is it a
new place or the same place
the same place oh you got it back
because it's not like they were kicking
you out or something
well yeah they kept blocking me out i've
been like that so many times and i i
think that's what made me stronger
because
you know like i said when i got back
there's lock on you know lock on my door
and everything like that and it's like
oh my god this is crazy you know what
i'm saying and
as much as i try to give him this trying
to get net and i'm still
and then at the end of the day the next
day i still get locked out because i
don't want you know i said oh
you got some nice help from my viewers
right you got some nice help from my
viewers
oh my god i'm totally shocked i'm
totally shocked right now
i think a lot of females really related
to your story me is like
that's that that makes me feel good
and i'm crying excuse me but
i want to thank everybody there's there
are a lot of doctors
for caring and
donation whatever i i totally didn't
expect none of this and especially
juliet thank you
much love love i appreciate it you know
it helps a whole lot i can get shoes now
yeah i know but
it must make you feel good too yes
somebody cares out there right
yes but it's so scary it's like
seriously because i didn't expect
none of this none of it and i'm like
really
just appreciative have you shared this
story with anybody like on
no i haven't even seen it myself
no i was totally embarrassed with your
friends and stuff you don't really
know i watched the benefit of my she
said i'm looking at your story right now
i said no don't do that don't look at it
you know
and she was like it's okay i was like no
you know no
i haven't looked at it you know to go
through this because there's shame
involved too right
a lot i mean you're not you're not to
blame for it but
but wow we all go through a lot but
a lot of things i've been through it's
just hard to talk about and tell about
it
and people close to me and people you
know i'm saying
that i i share you know a life with
foreign everything because people in the
streets we all
street family we're really like family
because we're all out here in these
streets going through the same thing
so we have nobody to depend on other
than ourselves
and we kind of like look out for each
other like my special friend
that you know came to me and told me
that about the
you know situation the donation i was
like seriously
i was like oh my god i can't believe it
you know i really can't believe it
i want to thank everybody that cares
because no one really cared
you know no one really cares about what
happens to us on the street
they look at us like oh they're just
[ __ ] they're just out there doing this
and doing that but it's not that
we go through a lot a whole lot
and we only have each other to be family
with we have
um real family yeah but
most of the time they're not
understanding to what we go through out
here
so we depend on each other for
moral support and everything you know
what i'm saying and like i said once
again i want to thank everybody
you know for caring mostly you know and
i appreciate the donations and
everything and thank you julia once
again
um i'm really nervous right now because
this is just such a shock to me i wasn't
expecting
none of this well i'm glad you look you
look happy and healthy
you know i've been trying i've been
sleeping a lot last time you look much
more stressed
well yeah yeah i was way way stressed i
think that's why i'm afraid to look at
my own interview i haven't seen it
i didn't know anything about the
comments or does it keep you up at night
or anything
um a lot of times
you know i sleep
periodically it's like if i sit still
longer than
a minute or two i'm asleep
you know because i really don't sleep
well i have nightmares
um you know sometimes it's hard for me
i've went into this like i've always had
a depression thing but like now
it's like it's trying to overwhelm me to
take over and i'm really
fighting it right now you know because
sometimes it's hard for me to just open
the door and go outside
go across the street to the store it's
just really hard
you know and i'm
dealing with it but i mean you know man
i don't know any counseling
and you know a little bit more help
i'm not talking about financially i'm
talking about millie and
and stuff like that because this tends
to take a toll on you you know
you're very strong no no i'm not
yeah you are i don't think so i go
through a lot
it takes a little it takes a lot for me
day to day
just to get up and do what i have to do
i i literally have to have drugs i mean
of course
marijuana or drink something to deal
with the streets now
i can't just i was down there last night
and the night before and i'm watching
all these girls and
they have to be old
i'm sorry you have to be on some kind of
something
but you have to you have to look your
best you have to have the right attitude
you have to be
friendly and personable and and they're
getting rejected over and over again
even though they're beautiful women but
they're they're getting crapped on left
and right and guys just like right
exactly because
it's like every guy drives up to him
says oh my god let me give you a bunch
of money and let's hang out
well i know one thing for sure i've been
blessed in kind of a certain way
but um to where uh the last few days
just seemed like it hasn't been
so hard for me i haven't had to
just be out there be out there like all
the time and do different people
because i've met a couple of friends
that for some reason they just been
really nice
and helped me with my rent and which is
like last night i watched the world
series
baseball game you know doctors lost
but you know it comes with a friend that
just happened to meet me
and they said they like my personality
and everything and so they helped me
so last night was one of the nights that
i had a chance to rest
that's nice i had a chance to sleep all
night
you know until about maybe 10 11 this
morning
you know yeah so i got
pretty much some rest last night but
then again and then it's like when i
wake up okay i'll be with him like okay
i got rest now it's time to go outside
i have to get into that aurora and get
dressed and try to feel
sexy you know so i can
attract attention and hurry up and get
what i gotta get
so i go back in the house you know
so basically
um
it's still up and down
i'm still in the middle of the ocean
fighting for the shore
once i get close to it i'm still getting
pushed back you know
nothing's changed about that you know
but
i'm still banking on myself to
try to be strong you know i mean you're
doing a great job
thank you you're doing a great job thank
you so much
i'm trying but i don't know right now
thank you very much for coming in again
okay and uh good luck with with
everything okay thank you so much
thank you
you